in our school matters series
stress-reducing exercises in mindfulness
are gaining popularity across the world
apps like headspace and calm have more
than a hundred million users combined
now schools are exploring how these
techniques can help students battle
mental health issues Roxana Saberi takes
a look at a one-of-a-kind study in
England giving students an education in
relaxation so feeling depressed sad
anxious at Arnold Academy north of
London students are learning to open up
my great auntie died at the weekend
about their anxieties worried because
list of concerns runs long there's so
much work to do I have lots of homework
they don't have like as much like
technology in social media there's a lot
of pressure on that to tackle these
tensions their school and nearly 400
others across England are trying
something new
today's a relaxation technique is called
wings to the sky short daily doses of
relaxation and as your arms are falling
you can feel your stress leaving and
mindfulness just try and relax and
release any tension over three years
researchers plan to study weather
exercises like these can improve the
mental health of children in England for
anxiety among kids is rising the trend
is similar in the u.s. a recent survey
found a 20 percent jump in American
children diagnosed with anxiety over
five years if we find that actually you
know this is beneficial then that's
great ice professor Jessica Dayton says
the government-backed trial in England
which she's leading is the largest of
its kind why do you think these
practices could be beneficial for kids
in the early piloting what they were
saying was their life is busy very busy
maybe busier than it was when we were
children and they find it's an
opportunity to sit and reset now they're
able to calm down and rationalize a
situation that's
why history teacher Rachel Bradford says
after just two and a half months of
these exercises Arnold Academy saw an 80
percent drop in reports of misconduct it
would be impossible for there to be such
a big reduction in behavior issues if it
weren't partly attributed to the
relaxation techniques 12 year old
Harrison says he doesn't get in trouble
like he used to just released my stress
and stuff and it's just helped me a lot
how many of you feel that learning
relaxation has helped you Olivia you're
not raising my usual way of like coming
down is to move so that's why I do dance
when you do like relaxation and
breathing it's like the complete
opposite so I don't really feel it so I
think there is a danger that people get
very carried away with one particular
approach I would say that's why it's
really important to do this research
because actually these practices may
turn out not to be effective and you're
gonna stretch up and try and catch the
balloon if researchers conclude that
these practices are effective supporters
hope all schools in England will
eventually offer that you can guy okay
I'm relaxed you've schools are not just
there to get children the best grades
that they can we're also here to help
our children become the very best
versions of themselves how many of you
think that adults should also learn
relaxation techniques techniques these
kids say all of us could learn from and
feel that stress leaving you Roxana
Saberi
CBS News Bedford England so stress in
childhood it's a real thing there's a
real thing I'm with little Olivia there
I don't want to do breathing exercises I
want to go out and run around you don't
want to do wings to the sky what do you
do here at CBS
[Laughter]